18 janvier 2020 pour la première fois
les médias évoque l'apparition d'un
étrange virus en chine un coronavirus
tous les regards se tournent alors vers
les scientifiques des spécialistes qui
avant de brandir la menace de pandémie
se voulait encore rassurant le 21
janvier la ministre de la santé est
optimiste
le risque d'introduction en france deux
cas liés à cet épisode est faible ce qui
n'empêche pas dès le 21
les autorités sanitaires de présenter un
plan d'action national et de lancer une
pré alerte sur l'ensemble du système
sanitaire français
les agences régionales de santé et les
samu du côté des hôpitaux
l'heure est encore à la sérénité
l'hôpital bichat est fier de présenter
ses sept chambres stériles aux médias
une casaque des lunettes une charlotte
un masque et une fois qu'on est prêts on
peut rentrer dans la chambre on va
pouvoir examiner et
même optimisme du côté des spécialistes
je ne crois pas que actuellement il ya
des raisons d'être inquiet pour nous ça
n'est jamais qu'un virus respiratoires
de bulles
côté recherche on s'inquiète du mode de
transmission du virus
puisqu'on ne sait pas c'est si des
personnes sont contagieuses avant d'être
symptomatique c'est un élément
absolument clé l'ambiance change à la mi
février
la france compte onze cas avérés il nous
faut préparer notre système de santé à
faire face à une éventuelle diffusion
pandémique du virus et donc à une
circulation du virus sur le territoire
national fraîchement nommé au ministère
de la santé olivier verrons qui remplace
agnès buzyn intensifie le plan sanitaire
les médecins de ville se retrouve en
première ligne sans protection ils sont
les premiers à alerter sur les pénuries
j'ai une vingtaine de masse en sachant
que
chaque match on a une efficacité comme
quatre heures même tension du côté des
hôpitaux où les médecins comprennent que
la situation va vite devenir critique
cieszyn épidémie qui touche des milliers
et des milliers de personnes 6 à 5 pour
cent des gens qui doivent être amputés
en réanimation
alors qu'on a des lits fermés en
réanimation là ce sera autre chose
mi mars les voyants sont au rouge à
l'est
première région submergés de patients
les médecins hospitaliers appellent
officiellement à l'aide n'ont rien on va
on n'est pas prêt on n'est pas prêt on
fait le maximum et fille pour assumer
mais si l'épidémie continue comme ça on
sera bientôt totalement dépassé appel
entendu le 16 mars 2020 le président
emmanuel macron annonce le confinement
du pays pour limiter la propagation du
virus et éviter l'effondrement du
système médical français sous tension
[Musique]